all right what's going on everybody
this is the reuben report direct message
and according to the paperwork here i am
dave rubin today is march
15 2021 it's a rainy day here in los
angeles
ducks just appeared in my backyard clyde
chased him down
but that did not stop us from putting
together a tremendous show for you guys
before we get to it uh as always just a
reminder to click that subscribe button
right here on youtube
and that notification bell so that maybe
you see our videos in your feed
and we've got four stories today they're
all over the place i think you're going
to enjoy the show and i want to
make note that last week a few people
noted that i was a little angrier than
usual
i even said i believe on thursday that i
was a little more
dejected than usual just the endless
cascade of idiocy
related to cancel culture and nonsense
like it was really like i was looking at
the stories trying to figure out a way
to not make everybody feel crazy
and i was like lord help me like like
it's just all bananas
anyway i had a great weekend just like a
really nice relaxing weekend we went to
home depot yesterday did a ton of
projects around the house i'm feeling
refreshed
and uh and ready to roll back to my
normal self although a lot of you liked
angry dave
i saw a lot of comments saying oh dave's
angrier dave's
dave's he's you know he's all ginned up
he's ready to roll
there was a lot of joy related to that
and i'm gonna have to think about our
relationship
on that note uh we've got four stories
as i said uh number one the grammys last
night did you watch them
probably not nobody watched them nobody
really watched them except some blue
check people on twitter i did not watch
them but my crack
staff over here did uh give me all the
highlights and we're going to play some
stuff that is just
mind-blowing just really just the
absolute trash that these people push
on us is truly incredible the second
story we're going to cover
is that washington post just in the last
20 minutes we just added this one
has issued a major major retraction that
you're probably not going to see
on the blue and on news networks of cnn
and msnbc and probably not in the blue
and on newspaper new york times
because you may remember two months ago
when supposedly donald trump
called the georgia attorney general and
pressured him to find votes and do
illegal things
oh turns out that that's not what
happened now that they've listened to
the whole transcript
so they just issued a retraction on an
article they wrote in the washington
post
two months later after the uh election
you know after the inauguration of joe
biden uh then
that infallible fouchy guy he was on
chuck todd democratic operative chuck
todd who's got to meet the press show on
msnbc
uh fauci was on there and he's still not
sure when you can go to weddings people
he's not sure when he's going to let you
go to weddings so we'll talk about that
and then the fourth story which i had to
cover
and i've wanted to do a little more
international stuff in general
is that in scotland they just passed a
hate speech law that
is seriously seriously dangerous
and really just the next extension of
what i think
is just spreading like wildfire across
the west right now
and fortunately here in the united
states we've still got the first
amendment which protects us from some of
this stuff
while other countries in europe do not
have that all right so jam pack show as
i said i'm feeling good i'm caffeinated
i'm ready to roll before we do anything
else though let's talk about
ancestry.com
you know guys there are many paths to
finding your family story
whichever way you choose tracing your
family generations back
with a family tree or uncovering your
ethnicity with ancestry dna
it's easy to get started with ancestry
you could find a famous relative or
perhaps a photo of your great grandma as
a little girl
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history and yourself
after all the story of your family is
the story of you with the ongoing
pandemic it's easy to feel disconnected
from your loved ones but researching
your history is a fun activity the whole
family can enjoy
and the stories you learn about your
shared past can bring you closer
together i've mentioned
before that we've traced my family
literally over 200 years back already it
is pretty awesome
ancestry dna can reveal ethnic origins
and provide historical details
that bring unique family stories to life
ancestry dna doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from but can also
pinpoint the specific regions within
them
giving you insightful geographic detail
about your history
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
and learn how and why your family move
from place to place around the world
no other dna test delivers such a unique
interactive experience
grab an ancestry dna kit and start a
free trial to amplify
your discoveries with ancestry's
billions of records and now through
march 17th with ancestry.com st
patrick's day cell you can find your
family's connection
to ireland start exploring your family
today
head to my url at ancestry.com ruben and
get your ancestry dna kit
and start your free trial that's
ancestry.com
reuben and now back to me here we go all
right so the grammys were last night i
think americans
and probably people worldwide have just
had it with this hollywood horse crap
that they're throwing at us all the time
they don't give us good music anymore
they rarely
give us good movies there's a couple
decent tv shows
but then the idea of these awards shows
where they just pat themselves on the
back and then they
also tell us how racist we all are and
how they're gonna you know institute new
diversity but you may remember the story
a couple
months back where the oscars said
they're gonna have all of these new
diversity quotas in movies which is
racism like we're gonna hire x amount of
black people x amount of asian people
blah blah blah so they're instituting
racism into hollywood even though
hollywood was one of the most
racist backwards places on earth anyway
but they've just sort of ruined all
these awards shows and it is sort of a
shame because i think there is something
to be said
about a certain amount of pageantry a
certain amount of oh
these are the actors we love these are
the pieces of art that was created
and even to see some of their
ridiculousness like i live in la there's
a little bit of that
stuff that i like and the little bit of
celebrity culture that's not
all terrible so i'm not going to sit
here and tell you that it's all just
awful
but because everything is gone so woke
we cannot get anything
good anymore right we can't get anything
real when's the last time you saw a
piece of
art or listen to a song that was real
it's really hard to get through that
machine
well uh last night we're going to show
you two things that happened during the
grammys last night again i didn't see
them till this morning you know what i
watched last night
i watched the series finale of the
golden girls david and i watch the
golden girls pretty much every sunday we
watch like two hours of golden girls on
hulu
and uh we normally do it sunday morning
we got
busy at home depot so we were at the
season finale i was like we gotta finish
it tonight so that's what i watched i
watched the sitcom from nbc
saturday night 8 pm back in 1992
instead of the grammys and i assure you
it was much much better
but here's uh first cardi b uh
doing her whap song it's a very exciting
song good for the whole family
take a look
[Music]
get your bucket people that's what she
says so i've got a bucket here i don't
have a mop we couldn't find the mop
um but i've got a bucket i'm not sure
what she's doing with the bucket but i
know it's something not good
nothing good is going in that bucket
that's for sure um
now look i i don't care about the song i
don't care about cardi b i'm not sitting
here
part of the moral majority saying we
shouldn't do any of these things
but i think the juxtaposition of that
and the woman
dancing in the shoe with the money
flying at her
the juxtaposition of that versus some of
the things
that we've canceled recently some of the
things we have said
are too dangerous to continue
while we're talking about wap which
stands for wet ass [ __ ] and she's got
the bucket
and the whole thing now again i i'm not
saying that shouldn't
be allowed she's got a wet [ __ ] what
are you going to do about it
so fine um but the strange way we deal
with cancel culture the strange the
way that the mainstream version
of everything that we get is so out of
whack with reality so we took out
mr potato head because of because he was
a mister
and now he's just potato head he's got
no gender even though really
his gender was only decided whether you
put the mustache on him although i'm
pretty sure girls can have mustaches
now we took out aunt jemima right from
aunt jemima's
syrup so now we took a black woman off
of a bottle
we took uncle ben off his rice so we
took a black man off that so now you go
to the store there's only white people
on any of the products so did this come
from white supremacists or from woesters
you tell me we took we took out gina
carano because she said something very
true about demonizing
people politically so then disney asked
her i mentioned the golden girls a
moment ago
they hulu took an episode of the golden
girls off where dorothy's son
marries a black woman and the families
come together over race
using comedy to discuss something to
discuss
race in the late 80s they took that off
because there's a moment
where rose played by america's favorite
grandmother betty white and rue
mcclanahan
show up in blackface they're not in
blackface they're wearing facial masks
and then the black women see them and
it's a funny thing that happens
but we cancel all of these things was
there anything else i think i might have
had one more that was a good
cancellation one oh well of course dr
seuss we canceled dr
seuss that racist nazi bigot um and the
point is
that we get rid of all of these things
and then we say oh but
the woman with the leaking [ __ ] and the
bucket and the mop and the whole thing
and the girl dancing in the shoe that
that's all okay
again i'm not saying it's not okay she
can do whatever the hell she wants
that's not my kind of thing i like
frankie valley but you know
the point is we're the way we're
focusing on things
something ain't right something ain't
right
and we've got to be aware of it but it
continued on and this if you thought
that was weird
it continued on they had a video from
lil baby i did not know little baby
before this
not a huge fan of little baby uh but
here's lil baby
when i was growing up i was taught in
american history books
but africa had no history and neither
did i
[Music]
and of course i believed it
i didn't have much choice
gc63 ain't no more freeless steve i gave
him chance to chance a chance again i
even
told him please i ain't with fire i know
but at least we can turn the flames
[Music]
all right that was a little baby's ditty
there now he said a couple of things now
again i didn't know
little baby until this morning don't
really care about little baby i
you know i wish him success uh but he
said a few things there
in the song um that he was taught
american history
that africa has no history that he has
no history
he was taught he was a savage and that
basically you know
the white people save him i mean what
history books taught that
i took history in public school what
history books
didn't teach slavery maybe not the
perfect version of slavery that every
single social justice warrior would want
but who would ever say that he as a
person has no history whoever
would say that that slavery was not part
of american history nobody says that
nobody or that africa
has no history we learned african
history when i was in public school
again that doesn't mean that every
educational system is absolutely perfect
and i would say most
public education is now completely
craptastic because
of of the looksters but but the song
doesn't even make sense there then
then he says okay you pushed and pushed
and pushed in effect so now we're just
going to burn some stuff down it looks
like he's burning down a private house
and then he jumps on the police car and
everything else so again
he can make the art if some people like
it that's just fine
but we we are applauding or the grammys
or the system whatever you want to call
it
is applauding certain things but imagine
if a country singer
had sang a song about backing the police
and being a good
person and being a you know a good
father and taking care of your kids
you think that's going to win a grammy
so that's what i mean by
the mainstream is just collapsing like
mainstream
and again it hurts me to say this in a
way that that we're watching the end of
liberalism in a way that it's devolving
now
into just nothingness it's devolving
into all of the worst ideas instead of
any of the good ideas which is a very
weird thing which is why
i keep telling you guys i mean basically
you're woke or conservative right now
um but you know the grammys it's not
just they they can show you the the
woman with the leaky
[ __ ] and the guy burning down the
building they also had to remind us
several times during commercial breaks
that they're not racist they are
definitely not racist let's pull the
image up
uh the recording academy and cbs condemn
and denounce
all forms of racism sexism violence
anti-semitism and hate let's continue to
use
music to bring people together leading
with love
healing and sense of unity across all
lines of difference
okay so that's just a meaningless
driveless nonsensical statement
because they say uh what's the line here
oh it's just so perfect
they condemn and denounce all forms of
racism sexism
sexism violence violence
did you just see the video that i just
played i'm pretty sure a little baby
just burned down a building does that
count as violence ah
but they've been telling us violence
against physical things violence against
buildings
especially if there's no people in those
buildings that's not violence you know
tell that to the guy who
you know puts 30 years building his
restaurant and then they burn it down in
the name of tolerance
and you might realize that violence is
violence regardless of your political
agenda
anyway they showed that throughout
apparently as they were cutting into
commercial break so as they peddle the
most divisive stuff
that they possibly can get away with in
american society they also remind you
they're they're against
hate we must be better we're diverse
we're good all that stuff anyway i'm
guessing you didn't watch the grammys
and i'm guessing you're a better person
for it
uh guys before we move on let's talk
about start mail
you know free email services like gmail
and yahoo aren't really free i talk
about this all the time you pay
with your privacy and since those
companies have access to every email you
send and receive big tech can sell your
data
to the highest bidder from business
plans to medical records companies can
sell your personal data
to target you with intrusive ads and
open you up to identity theft
and phishing attacks that's why start
mail wants to secure your email
and make you feel safe again start mail
keeps your email private period
every email is encrypted even if the
recipient doesn't use encryption
which means big tech can't read scan
analyze or sell your personal
information
ever start mail also prevents government
agencies from spying on you like dragnet
operations with start mail
deleted means deleted when you delete an
email it's gone forever and start mail
uses their own servers
not amazon's which means they can can't
be put out of business like parlor
start mail is backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get unlimited anonymous aliases
the feature protects your main email
address from spam and phishing attacks
so when you're giving your email to a
company but want to protect your
identity start mail can generate a
shareable alias email so people can't
sell your info
and they can be deleted anytime here at
the reuben report we've been looking for
alternatives to google so we're excited
to start using
our new start mail account i don't trust
big tech and neither should you start
securing your email privacy with start
mail
sign up today and you'll get 50 percent
off your first year
go to startmail.com ruben that's start
mail with the t
s-t-a-r-t mail.com
ruben for 50 off your first year start
mail.com
reuben and now back to me so this story
just broke this just broke literally
15 20 minutes before uh we went live but
i had to add it because you may remember
that we had a little bit of a kerfuffle
around the election right and a lot of
people thought that the election
wasn't legit i don't want to get my
youtube uh stream taken down right at
this very moment but we
you know we've just everything there's
nothing to be questioned and we're
okay we're good to go blah blah blah but
you may remember that the washington
post
ran a big story and then and then some
of the audio got leaked all over the
place
um where it appeared that donald trump
was pressuring the attorney general
of georgia to find votes that didn't
exist and that trump was doing all these
bad things and of course everybody ran
with all of this stuff and the usual
blue and on suspects well now two months
later
two months later joe biden is apparently
the president of the united states two
months late two months later
washington post has issued a retraction
i'm gonna read it for you
it's it's just fascinating correction
two months after publication of this
story
the georgia secretary of state released
an audio recording of president donald
trump's december phone call
with the state's top elections
investigator i'm sorry i just said
attorney general it was the
elections investigator the recording
revealed that the
post misquoted trump's comments on the
call
based on information provided by a
source
trump did not tell the investigator to
quote find the fraud
or say she would be a national hero if
she did so
instead trump urged the investigator to
scrutinize ballots in fulton county
georgia
asserting she would find dishonesty
there he also told her that she had the
most important job in the country right
now
a story about the recording can be found
here the headline and text of this story
have been corrected to remove quotes
misattributed to trump
okay so this is seriously evil and this
is what mainstream media is they are
liars they are
all frauds i do not get everything
correct here guys but i don't blatantly
lie to you and if i make a mistake
i i address it i've done it several
times and no doubt i will do it again
now first off notice that they say a
source right based on information
provided by a source well okay
are you going to use that source anymore
did you fire that source how come
there's nothing about that
should this should we know who this
source is that planted this obviously
false information
like they don't do anything like that
now what they're gonna do
the headline and text of this story have
been corrected to remove quotes
misattributed to drugs
oh so we changed the headline from the
story two months ago now that it's
completely irrelevant
do you see why we've got a problem here
the mainstream media is an
abject failure when we when we talk
about blue anon this group of people who
push
stories that fit the narrative push the
covington hoax
push brett kavanaugh as a racist push
jesse smilette and all of these fake
stories
they will tell you that q somehow is the
fake thing
i don't care about you i've never paid
any attention to queue
i did i posted a thing on twitter
yesterday actually when i was leaving
home depot
there's a big building that they're
building right now and it's a bunch of
offices it's like a lived work space and
it's called the queue which is sort of
hilarious
but so maybe the q people now have you
know like a brick and mortar which i
guess would be
an issue but the point is guys that this
is what mainstream media is don't
pretend it's anything
other than that and this like no one's
going to see
this that's the thing this isn't going
to be covered on cnn the what you know
is new york times going to do a piece
now on the washington post retraction
that i have no doubt new york times
ran stories using the washington post
story originally the washington post
source
of course they're not there are no such
things as journalists anymore guys we've
got
journalists we don't really have
journalists uh but speaking of
journalists and not journalists nbcs
meet the press
which which once was the most important
i would say the most important political
show we had in america
you may remember uh tim russert was the
host of of meet the press he was one of
many hosts
the show's been on for probably four
decades or something but when i was
growing up and when i was first getting
into politics tim russert
was the host of meet the press he's
passed away since um but he was an
incredible host
it was obvious that he cared about
politics in a deep sort of meaningful
way
he was enlightened and interesting it
was always sort of unclear to me what
his
full beliefs were which i think was
important as
a somewhat non-partisan host of a major
sunday news show
uh but then eventually uh he did pass
away but i
think he retired before that i'm not
totally sure actually but any event
chuck todd
is now the host of meet the press and
chuck todd is obviously a democrat like
nobody doesn't think that chuck todd is
a democrat like chuck if you tweet that
you're not a democrat i'll retweet you
but anyway he had the infallible thouche
on again and they're talking about covid
and they talked about how he could be
real
climate change might cause more of these
things and it's a constant scare fest to
keep you
silent and locked in your room and
afraid of everybody else
but here's a fascinating little piece
just as we're as we're opening up the
country
right as things are starting to somewhat
get back to normal
orange man is gone the whole thing well
chuck asked him when we can get together
for weddings and the infallible fouchy
took it this way
when can people plan an indoor wedding
you know that's it that's a good
question and i think that's going to be
within a reasonable period of time
you notice what the cdc is doing they
gave up
excuse me i didn't need this calendar
what time of the year
you know i i can't give you that exact
date because it's going to absolutely
depend
and this gets back to our conversation a
minute or two ago
it's going to depend on the level of
infection in community
if we plateau and stay at
60 000 a day and go up with a peak
i mean you can make no prediction if we
keep going down
and get to a very very low level when
we're there
and we have a good proportion of the
people vaccinated
i think you're going to see weddings in
the normal way that we've seen it within
a reasonable period of time
but there's always the caveat that it's
not going to happen
if all of a sudden you have a surge oh
thank you infallible fouchy weddings in
a reasonable amount of time you know
it's funny
infallible fouchy last week was the year
anniversary to two weeks to flatten the
curb so what would you say is reasonable
would it have been a year from then
because we're past that point
he can't answer anything this guy this
guy is no longer someone
you should listen to like you you should
make choices for
yourself and if you want the vaccine you
should have the vaccine and if you want
to wear a mask you should wear a mask
and if you don't want to go out you
don't want to go to stadiums and you
don't want to go to big events
and if you want to sit in the basement
and have someone throw you fish heads
once a week
you should do all of those things but
the idea at this point
that if your children or your friends
are getting married that you're not
going to go to weddings or if a loved
one dies and you're not going to go to
funerals the things that they've done to
us
for the last year these people don't
give a [ __ ] about you i i just don't
know how to explain it any more than
that
in a reasonable amount of time okay
voucher now we're at 60 and if that goes
up then it won't be reasonable to go to
weddings and if it goes down
then a few people can go to weddings and
some people can't well what do you mean
what is that
this the idea that this would be done
federally is also insane
because what if we're just watching it
just completely disappear in all the
middle
middle of america more rural states and
then the big cities have other problems
should we all be living under the same
rules
i mean it's just enough already man it
really is
i really think what these people are
doing is such a mass
red pilling of americans it's just crazy
because who
unless you were the most sort of
brainwashed mainstream person who could
be watching fauci
a year later a year after
two weeks to flatten the curve a year
after
we've destroyed lives and the depression
and the alcoholism and kids not going to
school
and yet we see all of the leaders going
on vacations
and taking trips and doing sending their
own kids to school and doing all sorts
of stuff
and fauci wear masks don't wear masks
we're going to do this we're not going
to do this all of that stuff
like how could you did anyone watch that
i mean really
somebody in the comments tell me if you
still have faith in this guy
and fauci by the way i would love to
have you on the show i'll have you on
the show and i won't even i will have no
notes no papers
no nothing we will talk we can do it
live because this does not make any
sense to me anymore
in a reasonable period of time
reasonable i think we passed reasonable
so unless you have a time machine maybe
fauci's been working on a time machine
we're going to go back in time and it
would be about a year minus two weeks
that would be reasonable to me uh
otherwise i'm not so sure fouchy
uh okay guys i wanna do one more and as
i said i've been wanting to do more
stuff about other countries because i
think one of the problems is
we can become very myopic here in
america because so much of the world
revolves around
us and we export so much of the of the
goodness and the stupidity
across the world actually uh the french
president macron recently said that that
woke-ism is being imported from america
into his country and that that's a big
problem but in scotland they've got a
major major problem
in scotland right now so they just
passed a hate
crime bill in scotland that is a massive
massive assault on free speech we've got
a quote from the scotsman
the bill which consolidates previous
hate crime laws and adds new offenses of
quote
stirring up hatred against protected
characteristics
of religion age disability and
transgender
identity okay so a lot of this was
pushed by a justice minister
named his justice minister humza is his
name uh and here we have a couple quotes
from him here because he was one of the
main drivers of this thing he's
pakistani
originally from pakistan irrelevant he's
a full member of
scotland right he's a citizen of
scotland he's entitled to his beliefs
but he we have two quotes from him here
here he says this is parliament at its
best the new law protects the most
vulnerable
in our society and he says not a day
goes by that i'm not conscious of the
color of my skin
the first thing people see and notice
about me is the color of my skin
and they probably form a judgment about
me in relation to it
sometimes consciously sometimes
unconsciously so in essence if you were
to make comments
about people's skin color about their
age sexual orientation all of these
things
you can now be punished under the law in
scotland and it seems to me that justice
minister hamza in effect
is really revealing his own bigotry that
when he's saying well the first people
think
that they see when they see me is
something about my skin color well that
must be the way
he feels and as you guys know i say it
once or twice a week
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions so i'll i'll i don't know
this guy i don't know a tremendous
amount about him obviously
but i'll go out here and let's just say
for a second this guy isn't like a crazy
racist lunatic who's trying to destroy
scotland and western values but he feels
that there is
some degree of racism in scotland i've
never heard that scotland has a major
race problem but let's
let's pretend that he sort of thinks
that that exists and he's he personally
has dealt with some racism which i have
no doubt
that he has almost everyone in the world
probably
has dealt with some form of
discrimination against them regardless
of whether it was skin color
or gender or sexuality or something but
should we pass laws to say you can't
say things about these groups of people
now that's very different saying
things right is very different than
saying okay you can't
instigate violence about people right or
about a group of people or a specific
person that's very different right
that you can't do that in america either
even with our first amendment that's one
of the preclusions
that we have in the first amendment uh
but this general idea that
and this is by the way this is what
jordan peterson was
was worried about right can we pull the
quote up from scott uh the scotsman
again because this is what jordan
peterson was worried about years ago you
guys
you guys remember was it bill c i always
forget was it c16 or 17 it was 16.
bill c-16 jordan was talking about how
in canada
he did not want the government being
able to compel speech meaning that if a
transgender person walked
down the street and you said good
afternoon ma'am and it turned out to be
a man
that you could be in trouble so when
they say here that they're
consolidating previous hate crime laws
which add new offenses of stirring up
hatred against protected characteristics
of religion age disability
and transgender identity meaning are you
allowed to make fun of people anymore
like where does comedy fit into that
where does
where does the ability to just be a
growing mistaken confused person be
nothing good nothing good is going to
come out of this and i
i fear that we're going to see more of
this across the whole bunch of countries
in europe because they don't have the
protections that we have
the first amendment that we have here in
the united states and i and i wonder how
much longer we'll have it the more power
we give away to the workstars guys like
don't think that these people
won't keep coming for anything there's a
major push right now to get dc
statehood right which would only give
the left more power and dc
should not be a state the the founders
understood that
um dc is a place where all the
politicians and all the people come
right like they they should care about
where they live not the place that is
the seat of power and everything else
okay man a lot going on uh oh i have a
great interview that we just put up part
one this morning that that's a real
dissection of everything that's going on
with big tech and everything that's
going on with recalls and everything
else uh david sacks
who uh is the former ceo of paypal he
was in the paypal mafia with
elon musk and peter thiel uh he's a
great guy uh we just put part one up
this morning which is mostly about big
tech but we also get into some recall
stuff
uh he's he's up in san francisco where
he's fighting to get their ridiculous
uh district attorney chessa bodine i
believe that's his name they're trying
to get him recalled
and i pray it happens before they export
him and send him down here because our
rda down here is this guy george gascon
who of course was the d.a in san
francisco ruined that place and then
what happens
in progressive politics you move on like
a locust and ruin something else
so part one with david sacks is up on
youtube right now and of course the full
episode
is available ad free at
rubinreport.locals.com
i've been teasing it for a while but we
will have a couple major announcements
related to locals by the end of the
month
the latest and all right i feel
i feel pretty good people pretty pretty
pretty good all right have a great day
everybody see you tomorrow